when i admitted to my own friends who
thought i was really happy that actually
i'm really unhappy and they're all at
the gasps adele opens up to oprah
winfrey about her painful divorce are
you embarrassed because it was so
quickly
i'm just embarrassed that i didn't make
my marriage work their interview aired
as part of the adele one night only
prime time special on cbs i've just
heard from reliable sources it went very
very well
never mind i'll find
someone
[Music]
in between performances from a concert
at griffith observatory came intimate
moments from adele and oprah's
discussion do you call this is this the
divorce album
i think i'm divorcing myself on it the
grammy winner went there as she talks
about her divorce from simon kaneki and
how they experience inspired 30 her
first album in six years it feels like
an all-consuming pain and i'm like what
the hell happened i just from a very
young age just you know promised myself
that
when i had kids that we'd stay together
we would be that united family and
and i tried for a really really long
time adele went on to reveal one of the
turning points that changed everything
was there a moment when you knew
i do remember one of my friends we were
all we were answering these questions in
this
very bougie magazine
and it was
it was something like
what's something that
no one would ever know about you and i
just i just said it in front of three of
my friends i was like i'm really not
happy
i'm not i'm not living i'm just
plodding along when i admitted to my own
friends who thought i was really happy
but actually i'm really unhappy and they
all gasped adele and simon married in
2018 after seven years of dating and the
birth of their son angelo but she
announced they had separated in april of
the following year but i think it was
just
by us getting mad at us having our
wedding and i you know i take marriage
very seriously and it seems like i don't
you know now like you know almost like i
disrespected it by
by getting married and then you know
divorced so quickly and stuff like that
but
i think are you embarrassed because it
was so quickly
i'm just embarrassed that i didn't make
my marriage work okay but how did her
ex-husband react to the new album well
adele didn't go into details but she did
offer this nugget how does she feel
about
this album and
the story of the two of you coming
through your music i mean we don't sit
around and talk about it like how are
you feeling like you know easy on me is
that [ __ ] stream how are you feeling
we don't talk about it um but um he
knows i'm you know he knows what kind of
artist i am like and you know that i got
i have to dig deep and tell my stories
when she said dylan i've never met i go
what do you mean you've never met
they've never met leading up to adele's
big night gail king gave e.t her
reaction to bestie oprah's sit down with
the easy on me singer so she arrived
oprah went to go greet her
she saw what adele was wearing and she
thought
i think i'm going to change into
something else really
okay great they look great when you see
the two of them together you'll
understand and she was already wearing
something fabulous but when you see the
two of them together you'll know why she
made the choice that she made
[Music]
you